thanks for joining us for the final
episode of insecure's after show the
wine down
on this very special occasion we are
going to unpack our
epic series finale and why we ended the
show the way we did so issa are you
ready
i'm so ready to dive in
final clink well second to last clink
[Music]
so this final episode goes through a
series of time jumps and tells our story
as we pass through months and even years
of our characters lives and now that all
is revealed we see the way that things
close out for our characters so you
wrote the final episode which is very
fitting given the history of the show of
course so tell us in all honesty when
did you know you wanted issa to walk
into the sunset with lawrence from the
very jump of writing this season i think
i knew
that i didn't want them together and i
was very confident about that i was like
i want more for our girl and i felt like
we had told their love story and it
ended tragically but i still wanted a
healthy love story and so i was like
it's gonna work for issa and nathan the
more and more we started going into it i
was like that's not like i felt like
issa like i love him yeah but i know who
my guy is you know we toured with like
is it nothing isn't working is it crin
shawn is it you know what i mean like is
it somebody that we just pick up that's
like a random person that we have they
haven't followed right because we know
we're going to end on issa mali right we
always knew that but it still felt like
the level of investment of the person is
going to be like the most interesting
version of that is is lawrence and you
and i talked early on because one of the
things we wanted to explore about people
being okay right was this idea of well i
didn't get the things i wanted but like
is that okay yeah right it is and i
think that i didn't get the season two
fantasy that i thought that i was gonna
get with yeah in the end of season two
we're moving in we're married we have a
child together and in a way you get that
it's just not the way you thought it was
gonna look like but are you gonna be
okay yeah i think so obviously you know
when you're ending a series right
there's all this pressure of like
finales that have come before you right
like the sopranos finale and how people
feel about that or game of thrones
finale you know you don't want to end it
where everything is wrapped up all cute
because that doesn't seem right but you
also don't want to end it in a place
where like i've been watching five years
like to feel sad like but you want to be
honest right and i think
amy and eo be you know one of our
writers and our director really freed us
from the pressure of ending the show she
was like guys like let's just end it as
if these characters lives are just going
to continue on it's just weird jumping
out the plane yeah but they're landing
the plane we're not
exactly jumping out of it exactly the
ride still continues and that's what i
think felt really satisfying was that it
it took uh sometimes it's not about
where you end up it's really how you get
there and say that if like you and i or
us in the room are having real debates
in real time we want to put that in the
show and the debate that the girls
actually have in 507 of i don't want to
be a dumb you and i actually had
that dialogue that you and tiffany have
but that is the journey that people have
to go through and it took a year for her
or to you know whatever time for her to
process
i had to grow we wanted to use molly's
mom passing not just as this sort of
like dramatic thing that happens right
but it actually kind of in some way
refocuses our characters and like what's
important at the end of the day but like
life is too short and you sort of say
that when you're talking to lawrence
when you call
for his birthday and it certainly
resonates at the end of the episode when
you guys are sort of having that last
moment together before like before
molly's wedding so it is really nice to
see all those things kind of like
dovetail for these characters growth so
many tragic life events have pulled
friendships apart yeah and i know that
we didn't want that for issa and molly
but it could still you know make it
harder to get together and harder to
forge that bond we they've carried
throughout these seasons one thing we
talk about in the show is this love
story
between you and molly yeah um and
there's
a moment in the show when you are
helping her out of her dress but it is
kind of like the last moment we see you
guys actually like together in the frame
right so i'm curious what
that day was like and what does it mean
to you to have a show where for the most
part of this show these women were like
the best of friends family like sisters
everything you know um i think
about my own friendships and
i think about my friendship that's
developed with yvonne
over the course of you know six years
creating this and it was such an
emotional day you know it was issa
sending her friend off into the next
chapter of her life it was this moment
of
kind of reckoning and acknowledging
everything that they had been through
they
found each other and they've loved each
other through all of their flaws and
that thank you meant so much when we
started season one could you
imagine that fans would be so invested
or that they'd heard rashu online or in
person to make the show longer or get
mad when issa made life decisions or
dated certain men like did you think it
would just be
this i mean you know like we were in
such a vacuum yeah in that first season
especially we just wanted to get like to
stay on the air we just wanted to tell
our stories and tell it the way that we
wanted to you know you imagine this
audience of family and friends and
things like that but you don't know
who's gonna be watching the show and you
hope they like it but
i i get fake annoyed i get real annoyed
but it really is a true blessing to have
people so invested like these characters
aren't part of people's lives in such a
rich way and you can only dream of
creating characters like that you know a
lot of times in you know if you're in
the in the white world of hollywood if
you're making a black show it's like
let's get every black person everybody
black person knows already because we
just want to make sure people know these
people right but white shows kind of get
a chance to take a chance on an indie
person that you've never heard of before
right and i think that was the thing
that i thought you were so smart in the
beginning was like let's kind of do what
spike lee did find people that will grow
out of that right and like the next wave
of of black talent and so you got to
personalize and make issa be whoever you
wanted easter to be for yourself same
with molly same with lawrence they felt
like every people right and so i think
that helped always keep the show feeling
like oh that's not like
you know
denzel washington as his dad i think
that helps you become more also invested
when we first met and sat down like not
too far from here actually you know for
me my goal was always like hey i want to
make sure you get to tell the stories
you want to tell but you obviously had a
different challenge too because you had
to adapt it from a a web series right
into like a totally different form in so
many ways so the web series was what it
was and i wanted to create something new
for this this network
and i don't know that i had the
expectations
of where i wanted the series to go where
i wanted every character to go i knew i
knew the journey that i wanted to take
them on
but
like this has exceeded everything that i
imagined that it would be in the best
way and i'm just i'll i'm
forever grateful for that what i think
is so great about the show is like
getting to watch it
change and grow with each person that we
brought on so like i read the script one
way but then we brought molina on and it
like elevated it into
another place and you just continue to
see this thing grow and grow and grow so
just to piggyback your point i totally
agree with that yeah the people
behind the scenes made the show what it
is i agree
you know the city in which like we both
grew up in la is a huge part of the show
you know and you know we always talked
about the way that scorsese or spike lee
or woody allen sort of make these sort
of love letters to new york right why
was it important for you to sort of make
a show that was sort of a love letter
not just to l.a but the specific part of
la that normally doesn't get seen i
think it's that you know it's what you
just said and it's just i feel like la
is always represented as either
hollywood the glamour and glitz or the
hood and the in-between doesn't really
exist um especially the in between as it
relates to us right and
um
that was so important
for me to portray the finale was
initially half of it was gonna be in
morocco three-fourths of it was gonna be
in morocco just to pay off issan mali's
like the fantasy destination and it was
a great episode it was but it wasn't in
l.a and it just didn't feel right so we
wanted to give la a good ending as well
yeah like we also had a a rihanna
impersonating
revival rebounding rebounding
baba that's our rihanna fake rihanna
concert in morocco so uh so apprentice
in your opinion is issa finally secured
i think so but i they say the question
is the word like final has a weird thing
on it right i think you and i have
always talked about and this was i think
we talked about this almost day one
about the series was that
the real ending of this show is when you
get secure in your insecurities and
knowing the insecurities won't ever
leave right and so
it's understanding that i'll go through
ups and downs and all that but i don't
have to have these sweeping reactions
like in you know the first two seasons
this is always like this thing happens
i'mma be a no or i'm gonna
be at this i'm gonna be at that as
opposed to being like you know what i'm
gonna ride
this wave a little bit and just be
uncomfortable as it's uncomfortable and
then grow out of it so if i was to say i
think she finally recognizes that
real security comes from understanding
there kind of is no final version of
being fully secure
well said
to our dedicated viewers we thank you
guys for riding with us for the past
five seasons and we hope that you
enjoyed this journey as much as we did
we will miss you insecure we hope lives
in your hearts
forever
thank you guys for walking with us and
for letting these characters into your
homes every sunday thank you nobody has
to tweet and make it our anymore
bye y'all thank you
cheers
you